here is Andrea Mitchell on MSNBC saying
that Maricopa County which is where some
of the crazy irregularities were they're
just the best you got to trust these
people over at Maricopa and Mark let's
talk about what we learned from for
instance what's happened out in Maricopa
County what's left out there in terms of
how the vote keeps you know coming in
despite all of what has been said by
Donald Trump and other election deniers
and now beginning to be also Kelly Ward
who's falling behind about uh you know
Katie Bob Hobbs but the governor's
phrase
Maricopa County has some of the best
vote counting processes because of pass
problems yeah Andrea they have a whole
lot of practice
first off she doesn't sound very
confident as she's saying it but if
Maricopa County has some of the best
processes then why did it take them an
extra six days actually you want to know
about some of the best processes uh you
could try Miami which was formerly blue
right you could try uh Tallahassee you
could try Orlando you could try any of
the counties and the cities in Florida
where things were smooth and easy and
that's all because the Republicans went
out of the way DeSantis and Marco Rubio
went out of their way to secure
elections just make sure it's legit not
cheat but make sure IDs Paper Trails Etc
you get it so how is it possible why
would she even say that how would how
could you look your audience Andrea I'm
talking to you lady I do a similar thing
for a living right we're both talking to
the camera how can you look at the
camera Andrea and say to your audience
that they have some of the best
processes when it's six days after when
the election was supposed to be called
come on lady anyway here's Maricopa
County official Megan Gilbertson and she
is not instilling any confidence in
what's going on over there somebody's
gonna have to tell Andrea Mitchell but
the possibility that they're slow
rolling the vote we checked in with
those election officials about the
process why it's taking so long here's
what they told us
this is fast for Maricopa County it
usually takes us anywhere between 10 and
12 days to complete the count and we
think we're going to be done by the end
of this week
you know it's interesting how MSNBC
frames things so they bring this woman
in to say oh it took a long time but uh
you know it's still working and it's
pretty good but that's not evidence of
anything right that's not evidence that
it's good just because she says it's a
little faster than it would normally be
why is it still broken how about that